in your book yes gutsy women great I got
to disagree with one of them that's
right controversy Sally Ride your point
she was the first female astronaut
American she died
because you at the time I felt now you
as a mother might be able to answer this
better than I she shouldn't have gone up
in space she had a young child at home
no she did no you're talking about the
wrong wrong time at the wrong woman all
right who am I talking about Mae Jamison
maybe but you know let's talk about
Christa McAuliffe
I know why you didn't agreement she was
no I don't agree with you no no she she
was a schoolteacher she was selected to
be an astronaut what a great honor and
she trained she had no reason to believe
it was going to be a disaster the way it
turned out
so if women didn't do anything once they
had children I think that would be a
great loss Helen Keller you're right
listen no one can know because I mean
housing blind yep death yep okay can't
do anything right and I also highlight
and Sullivan her teacher because what a
great great instructor she was to get
Allen colored unlocked for the world yes
would did you consider Caitlyn Jenner no
think about this I do though have Danica
roam aha Danica roam is a transgender
woman who ran for the Virginia State
Legislature and won and was just
re-elected Caitlyn Jenner it listen
anybody who is transgender in our
society has got to be brave I mean come
on it is right right I think it's an
especially a Bruce Jenner who yeah yes
this amazing recognizability and history
and then has this problem I have to
admit I'm like wow Bruce Jenner of all
people the guy in the weeds you watched
him in the Olympic oh my god
by the way was there ever a better
looking guy in terms of busy ruse Jenner
when he was in the Olympics or your
first boy
that's a tough one who is better-looking
your husband bill or the Greek god
boyfriend Wow different totally
different looks very diplomatic
recognize Bella Abzug award Bella
fabulous congresswoman right and you
know and and and and did you know and I
you know we could have written 100 page
books about these women we only had a
few pages she was also a great civil
rights lawyer I mean she was down in
Mississippi defending people who were
charged with crimes they didn't commit
she was amazing and you know why she
would get ridiculed because of the way
she looked of course in a way what
you're saying with this book is listen
these are women who have to be
recognized this is your version of the
Academy Awards yeah you were saying to
history let's not forget these women
right and and to people today who I hope
will read it meet these women find out
about them wired know you know who I
would put in there who Joan Rivers what
do you think of that that's an
interesting idea and asked me do you put
in geraldine ferraro
this is another one I take exception
with oh because I feel geraldine ferraro
cost the election from Walter Mondale I
mean who knows I mean we don't want to
sell all right maybe that's a bit strong
yeah but geraldine ferraro knew her
husband was a questionable kind of
character she didn't when she was being
vetted she didn't come clean when I
think I'm click she could have
volunteered some information and said I
might be a problem I have a I have a
different take on that okay and and and
it's this I know her husband I do not
believe that a lot of the allegations
against him were at all fair or
well-founded okay but we were just
getting into the era
people would be picked apart in a way
that they had never anticipated before
and so I think yeah were they ready for
that no but who was and and so I think
her I mean her political career her her
energy the way she presented herself and
then she too toward the end of her life
had this you know blood cancer right and
she she went to Congress and testified
about it she was very open about it I
know I'm wrong I would I would I
wouldn't put how you're winning this
debate but you in my book I included
Ellen DeGeneres and you included Ellen
and she is a hero to me
she's a hero to me too you know I
remember when she came out she had the
sitcom she came out I was very proud of
her because again in show business I
don't care what you say we remember the
days of Rock Hudson when he comes out
that's the end of his leading man career
and even today when somebody comes out
it's a big to-do right and she and and
is that the reason you admire her yes
and the way she handled it yeah I mean
she is the one who finally said I can't
continue pretending I'm somebody I'm not
what did you think when she got
criticized she's sitting next to George
Bush and she was joking around with him
nothing wrong with that that was insane
right more of that right
Sybilla come on civility decorum
listening and talking to each other
enough with the chants and the insults
let's have a conversation do you know
what she was showing George Bush at the
time on her phone I do not a painting of
mine that I did a watercolor you are
kidding me
Allen told me that well because I got it
probably you should talk to Baba paint
it I am a water colorist than he is a
water colorist and she thought it would
be and she's an admirer of some of my
watercolors that is terrific in that
crazy did you take lessons like he did I
did take lessons I still do for you I
love it what do you do for fun because I
would imagine you need something
you're a lawyer the greatest degree
right did Chelsea get a window she's now
she got a PhD in international relations
public health I know that's funny yeah
my daughters in the middle of getting a
PhD it's not she getting it in she will
be in psychology it's really hard it's
an it oh my god she's huge commitment I
am so proud of her she's breaking her
butt getting that thing good but but no
but when you when you think about it
that Ellen DeGeneres top notch I mean
you say who's gonna argue with Anne
Frank of course but the one I like is a
greta thunderbird this girl what i mean
cuz we heard about her you know we were
writing a book last spring and we heard
about her little lonely climate strike
all by yourself in front of the swedish
parliament about a 16 year old little
sign but these people are like angry
with her the calling her [ __ ] that's
because they can't stand the truth
especially from a young woman and listen
if i was a young person i'd be in a
panic about the way we've handled we are
we are condemning our planet and it
makes me sick you would have been
something with the environment i feel i
feel you would have been on it i would
have been totally on it would we have
done what would we have done when we if
you had done I said you should have been
the president well we we could have done
a much faster move toward renewables you
know remember I got into all this
trouble saying that you know coal was
going to be you know it was going to end
and it is we had all these bankruptcies
of coal companies I mean I was telling
the truth
unfortunately you should have lied I
should have lied I guess because you
know if you're too truthful you end up
turning off some it's a problem almost
everyone lies because even when you say
there's guys even when you see Bernie
Sanders and this was a perception I had
you would say a policy when you were
running against him for the nomination
right and the next thing you go yeah
well free college for everyone yeah it's
almost like when you run for a fifth
grade class free
any more research and then it makes it
look like you're a stick anomaly then
would you say well wait a minute where's
the money gonna come from then what a
matter are you against free college who
else you have on the list let me go real
quick because I've held you here way too
long
Billie Jean King I get that also when
she came out much you know before Oh and
lost all of her endorsements or
sponsorships especially everything that
happens in the world of sports
based on Billie Jean King equal pay yes
right right by the way your book is
number one it is good well your
publisher Simon & Schuster buy an ad for
you because you know my book came out of
number one and they said to me I said I
want you buy an ad they go no no no you
just talk but you've always been number
one no but I wanted a little Tooting my
own horn
it's it who is your did you work with
the Jonathan Karp I did look at you nice
guy right very mark and Priscilla
paintin was also very helpful
she was good yeah I had a terrific
editor to let me see who else you got to
go to Bob's Maya Angelou I don't get
poetry I just can't personality I'm
gonna book because I do need to I need
more history if you read Howard Zinn's
book Oh a long time ago or is it the
recent one I just don't know what I'm
talking about he's his classic ancient
because I rely had unlike you I did not
pay attention at all yeah I had other
things you so much I and this is a this
is important for me to know why is Maya
Angelou great okay I will say number one
we were talking about childhood have you
ever read her book I enjoyed the Caged
Bird Sings yeah
listen this child I told you the books
I've read this she was a little girl and
she was raped and she stopped speaking
for two years but while she was not
speaking she was reading in this little
tiny
a segregated town in South Arkansas
called stamps she would she read every
book in the quote colored library then
she went and tried to get books out of
the white library and she memorized she
memorized Shakespeare and she memorized
Langston Hughes and then she recreated
herself I mean it's such an amazing
story you know and she read the she
wrote a poem pulse of the morning that
she read it bills inauguration yeah it
was just breathtaking
so she became a friend of mine but her
life story her accomplishments she was a
Renaissance woman but she gave maybe
Robin do you she gave courage to a lot
of absolutely absolutely really did I
believe she is the creation of Oprah
Winfrey when you say when you say you're
friends with these people I mean like
you'll get together and hang yeah when
when when I got to know her yeah before
we don't hang with these people usually
at a private home oh yeah yeah use it
weird no it's great are you kidding it's
great it's it you know first of all I'm
like any other person it's it's so
exciting and interesting to see people
that I admire sort of behind the scenes
what are they like how do they behave
you know and to be with somebody like
her and I remember I visited you get
nervous when you go to see these people
like oh like what if I'm like I might
get nervous with some like I think I was
nervous the first time I met Nelson
Mandela oh I thought he was the most
amazing human being in the 20s who do
you know could live in a prison his
entire life think about for a Cause okay
let me tell you my favorite Mandela
story teller he gets out of prison he
has said many times when I walked out of
prison I knew I had to let the hatred go
or I would still be in prison first of
all you that said you got to work on
yourself because it's not easy so I go
to his inauguration he gets elected
president and I'm with a huge wonderful
American delegation lots of people who
had supported him had been
anti-apartheid activists plus people
from around the world who had supported
him like Fidel Castro and you know
unfortunately at that point in time I
couldn't say hello to Fidel crass
so I was constantly avoiding him but we
get to the delwood always there so we
get to the lunch and it's in this huge
tent on the President's House lawn and
Mandela gets up and he says I want to
welcome everyone all of all of these
very important people
all these VIPs but the most important
people who are here for me today
are these three men calls them by name
ask them to stand they were three of his
white jailers oh my god and he said
these three men in all those years
treated me with dignity they treated me
like a man a person so I'm sitting there
thinking man I I'm fighting with
Republicans over health care you know
people are saying crazy things and
here's Nelson Mandela literally modeling
what you should strive for so when you
thinking of oh my god it was amazing I
had the best times with him I'm so moved
by him what a guy what an what a world
we live in when you got guys like that
there are amazing people it's like the
second coming of Jesus Christ it's
people who who work on themselves like
you did going to therapy but read it to
you yes work on yourself you because you
know Mandela and I spent a lot of
personal time with him over the years
and he would say to me he said I was a
really angry young man I was angry at
the world I hated white people I hated
our conditions I hated everything and I
realized that was killing me on the
inside so you have to be self-aware
enough and he was you mean he didn't
lead Allah corruption against his
opponent or anybody else Hillary Clinton
won an honor to meet you it was fun oh
my goodness it really was just something
I I wanted you to be President so bad
Thanks thank you that's why you know I
reached out but I I don't know if I went
through the right channel I did not know
the New York Times and I don't do a lot
of interview so I went in the New York
Times The Washington Post and I was
openly begging you
I had you know it's a weird thing that I
just tell you this real clear it's a
weird thing there was a guy in radio
years ago when I first got in lis Abrams
very brilliant guy and he would talk
about the audience and he would analyze
the audience and he would talk about
that he would label the audience there
were certain people who were this that
the other thing and then he would say
there's also Earth's dogs earth dogs
this is the way he would analyze and
he'd say um you have a lot of earth dogs
it wasn't a negative it wasn't a
negative word it meant a certain type of
guy working-class guy this is what he
believes this is what he's doing and I
listened to the research because why not
it's there and it's free right so when
you were running and I'm talking about
going back even as far as when you were
running against Obama trying to get the
nomination I said this woman has done it
all senator you know I'm going to
secretary state yet but but you would
you know White House you well spoken
Yale the whole the whole thing I knew
the whole thing and I thought this is
gonna be some spectacular presidency in
the same way I feel about bills
presidency you know this is going to be
spectacular and the two of them together
is spectacular
and I figured maybe if he came in and in
the end during the 2016 election I could
talk to you like a person and maybe say
did the earth dog audience this is a
cool woman she really cares maybe maybe
you don't get her a hundred percent but
she cares she's devoted her life to
public service she's a public servant
she likes people and then maybe I don't
know maybe a couple more votes there who
knows that was what I was thinking but
you know what I think you were right and
I think that I didn't know about it but
I probably would not have done it if I
had known about it because of my
reputation well and and also it just you
know in a presidential campaign the
priorities I often did not prioritize
media the way I should have and I think
that's one thing that you know Trump
would interview in it with anybody and
in his pajamas they would take
and so he was just a constant presence
and you know I I mean I think I made a
miscalculation I do well listen because
you're a no-nonsense person you're kind
of like you know what I just want to get
to work I know you're enough to get in
there and really make some moves yeah
yeah true but I would see you're doing
so few other radio shows who knows if I
want to move the needle you know I would
like her to address cuz she was the
secretary of state you know we keep
hearing this term deep state deep state
deep state who are these people you know
this is a term which was coined by
political scientists to describe certain
countries like for example Pakistan
mm-hmm where the military and the
intelligence services basically ran the
country and so you could get elected but
if they didn't like them like what you
were doing or you cross them you were
out well maybe you'd get arrested you'd
get deported you get accused of
something in one case you'd get
assassinated or executed so it has a
very particular meaning and when it
started to be used by Trump in his
associates about the United States it
was so wrong headed and I think we've
seen that in impeachment who are they
aligning their maligning career military
their their maligning career foreign
service officers their maligning we need
be civil servants these are the people
who run government from administration
to administration and you know these I
know these people and you know what they
are not all Democrats they are
conservative they are liberal they are
Republican they are Democrat but they
put country first that's what I said
they're Patriots many times and they are
not in any way plotting against the
president but they do have an obligation
like the whistle blower saw when they
see something that
is an abuse of power and let's not mince
words Trump was trying to bribe the
president of Ukraine to take action by
announcing the beginning of an
investigation on an unfounded theory
against his domestic political opponent
for his own personal and political gain
I mean if you're a if you want to write
a novel like that you can't make it out
it's crazy I think anybody would I'm
very I listen I am so disenchanted
listen yes Hillary and Chelsea Clinton
you got together with your daughter you
wrote a book yes and as I say I would
markup this as the Academy Awards of
women thank you who are the women that
you Hillary Clinton say are cutsie yeah
this is what we're talking about right
right why am i yelling I feel like you
can't hear me I'm gonna say God see
women is available wherever books are
sold right and we know where that is I
don't have to go through the list and
and and and promotion I would assume for
Christmas why not a Christmas and
Christmas you hand someone my book and
your book this morning that's a natural
come on I mean wow wouldn't it be
something well I am honored to have met
you I mean this is exciting for me I've
met Paul McCartney he's a good one do
you love him I love him baby
I didn't faint you know my sister loved
Fabian back in the day my sister's a
little older than me yeah everybody
loves it oh yeah what the hell are you
baby you were in the Fabian fan Clyde
what tell your sister I was I was the
president of the Fabian saying that now
in light of history I was so young and
he was so cute yes yes yes but of the
Beatles it was Paul it was always Paul
yeah what you know what to me those guys
were they taught me more than anyone and
still do they do I mean you put on White
Album you listen to that you learn
something in
every time it's unreal it is unreal I
was thinking of a John Lennon lyric do
the Danny went oh that's what he meant
I'm just starting to get it yeah Hey
Jude I mean think about it all of it all
of I mean I find his I find their music
to be so not just part of my past like
like I have a lot of music that's part
of my past this is I past my present in
my future
were you a rock fan I was yeah you
wouldn't go to a Zeppelin concert though
would you
no I didn't ever I didn't but I went to
the first Rolling Stones concert that
ever came to Chicago back in the early
you know to mid 60's
are they the world's greatest rock and
roll but they're amazing they are they
are amazing because of the amount of
material that this band put out yeah and
look they're staying power their stamina
it's inspirational people how is he
alive that's the more interesting
question yeah I mean there's something
to investigate but his book was
brilliant heaps oh god yes how does the
how did the Rolling Stone stay together
after Keith slaughtered a Mick Jagger in
that book Mick is a really pragmatic guy
he doesn't drink and he works out every
day it's Mick like do you know Mick I do
I never met him
where do you meet Mick oh gosh I've met
I met him first probably in the White
House
I don't came to see you when you're in
the White House you can invite anybody
to come see you what do you say to these
people you know just do you fan out over
them or my mother loved the Rolling
Stones that's that's the Rolling Stones
were at the Beacon Theatre I think it
was a Scorsese filming so we were
invited I brought my mother I thought
she was gonna pass out and you know her
favorite was Keith Richards oh yeah so
because my mother loved Keith Richards
we asked if he would call her on her
birthday
and he did it was like the best birthday
she ever had is there a lot of
discussion with your husband about
whether it's appropriate to call Keith
Richards and ask for this favor or did
you just go ahead and do it I mean go
ahead and do it really yeah we got to
know them over over time and Keith's
like yeah I'll call your mother that's
great and then Keith we were we were
vacationing we're near where he had a
vacation home he came over and saw my
mother you know
unannounced
says hey I'm gonna come he knew we were
there we had come and this was you know
years ago he came by does he jam it all
or just no he just talks just talk does
anyone understand what he's saying
actually I make the comparison to Nelson
Mandela not on the same level I mean
obviously but but the fact that that
that Mick Jagger could be in a band with
this guy who now bad-mouths him that
book Keith just it just basically says
the most horrible things about him be
like if you hung out with Trump after
all the things right that would be hard
but Keith treats Mick like he's top well
but they've been together for so long
and I think I don't know I think they
understand each other unbelievable Wow
you've seen it all haven't you now that
I'm hoping to see more you want to see I
want to see more I'm yeah I want to see
more why not got one life yeah I want to
keep going I'm enjoying myself to a
degree yeah you've got grandkids now you
want to watch them grow oh my gosh I've
got three grand adorable to be honest
how much time can you spend with them
before you're ready to run out of the
room they spend a lot really but I will
tell you it's exhausting yeah get ready
because what happens to you
Oh oh my god this is so wonderful and
then you're like lying on the floor made
you can't do it five-year-old a three
year old a four month old when I look at
Alec Baldwin who's an older guy and he's
got young kids really dad how is he
doing that he you know he's a good sport
about it he really is I saw him I saw
him a few months ago and he just like
has totally bought into it he is so
present he takes those kids everywhere
he does everything legal - I had dinner
with him right yeah and we admit
involvement of charity and blah blah
blah and we have done and he's got
little babies got little kids and he's
like oh this is great I know you must
have a lot of help but we saw that mean
he's at Madison Square Garden all the
time yeah I got the high sign you gotta
go I apologize for keeping you so long
but I am a big fan then who knows when
I'll ever see you again
Hillary and Chelsea Clinton's book the
book of gutsy women what they're saying
to you is there are
out there maybe you'd learn something
about you're sitting there you're
playing video games and you're not
learning anything
this could teach you something it's
available wherever books are sold
I will read this on my Kindle thank you
I would like to learn I hope you will
I'm gonna do it'll be well and a special
thank you to janitor John that basically
got this couple together bill anyway a
lot of fun thank you thank you and we
will be back after this run for recap
and Madam Secretary
this is president Hillary Clinton your
lips to God's ears right who knows maybe
we'll don't run again you know what you
don't need you're not running again sit
home do whatever you want
screw everyone they messed out and let
me tell you something I'm plenty scared
after what you said about what's going
on behind the scenes and all of that all
of the disasters we live we need a calm
steady hand right now we got lots of
issues we didn't even get into those we
should talk about those again sometime
no come back we'll come back in about 15
minutes just pencil in a free day thank
you so much thank you